Hallo ihr Lieben! So viele haben mich gefragt, ob ich nicht ein XXL Kinderjoy machen könnte
und natürlich konnte ich euch den Wunsch nicht abschlagen.
Und hier ist es nun: mein Riesen Kinderjoy für euch.
Damit das Kinderjoy auch 100% essbar bleibt, habe ich die Plastikverpackung, in der sie typischerweise ist,
aus Candymelts hergestellt.
Außerdem benötigen wir noch die passende Form.
Ich hab hier eine Halbei Form aus Plastik, die ähnelt dem Kinderjoy zu 100%
und ich empfehle sie euch auch weiter und verlinke euch das mal in die Infobox
Da die Candymelts im geschmolzenen Zustand allerdings überhaupt nicht herunterfließen,
und wir unbedingt diese Konsistenz brauchen, gebe ich hier noch ein wenig geschmolzenes Kokosfett mit hinzu.
Nun haben sie die perfekte Konsistenz, sie sollten so ein wenig vom Löffel herunterfließen
können und dann geht's weiter mit der Form.
Der Vorteil dieser Form ist übrigens, dass der am Boden abgeflacht ist, so können wir
ihn auf die Arbeitsfläche stellen, ohne dass er uns umkippt.
Und jetzt können wir auch schon direkt starten und geben
die warme Candymelt Masse in die Form und schwenken das hin und her.
Sobald die Form komplett von den Candymelts bedeckt ist,
können wir den Überschuss zurück in die Schüssel geben,
mit einem Messer dann nochmal abstreifen, und dann muss das Ganze
einmal im Kühlschrank komplett auskühlen.
Dann wiederholt ihr den gesamten Vorgang, damit
die Form auch stabil ist und die Wand halt nicht zu dünn ist
und wenn ihr dann noch Unebenheiten habt, dann begradigt sie ruhig mit dem Messer.
Was auf dem Boden der Form allerdings ist, ist eigentlich total unwichtig, denn da kommt später
sowieso die Creme hinein.
Nun geht's weiter mit den zwei Kugeln und dafür nehm ich mir hier so eine Toffifee Verpackung
und kleide sie mit Frischhaltefolie ein.
Anschließend nehmen wir uns Waffelblätter,
die findet ihr in jedem russischen Supermarkt
oder auch in größeren Supermärkten.
Und dann nehmen wir uns immer Stück für Stück und kleiden
die Toffifee Form damit ein.
Das ist ein bisschen Fummelarbeit, aber wenn ihr das geschafft habt, könnt ihr weitermachen
mit der Nutella, mit der wir dann die Kügelchen befüllen.
Ich hab sie mir einfach in einen Spritzbeutel getan, vorne die Spitze abgeschnitten
und jetzt befülle ich die Halbkugeln damit.
Jetzt muss sie nur noch an der Oberfläche glattgestrichen werden,
denn anschließend setzen wir immer zwei Halbkugeln zusammen
und so mache ich weiter, bis ich 4 Halbkugeln habe.
Das wandert jetzt zum Aushärten 15 Minuten lang ins Gefrierfach,
und dann können wir weitermachen, indem wir sie zuallererst aus der Form befreien.
Nachdem wir sie dann auch von der Frischhaltefolie befreit haben,
tunken wir eine Halbkugel in geschmolzene Vollmilchkuvertüre
und setzen sie mit der anderen Halbkugel zusammen.
Das gleiche tun wir dann auch mit den anderen Kugeln und
dann kann das Ganze nochmal zum Aushärten in den Kühlschrank.
Sobald die zwei Hälften dann zusammenkleben, tunken
wir sie zuallererst in geschmolzene Vollmilchkuvertüre und anschließend in die Schokostreusel.
So sieht die erste Crispy Kugel nun aus und das Gleiche
machen wir auch noch mit der zweiten.
Und jetzt geht's weiter mit der weißen Creme.
Dafür habe ich hier weiße Kuvertüre geschmolzen
und außerdem noch gezuckerte Kondensmilch in der Mikrowelle erhitzt.
Ganz wichtig ist, dass die zwei Bestandteile auch heiß sind, damit
sie sich gut verbinden lassen.
Und nachdem wir dann fleißig gerührt haben, ist die weiße Creme auch schon fertig.
In der Zwischenzeit ist unser ich sag mal "Plastikteil"
vom Kinderjoy schon ausgehärtet und wir können das ganz leicht aus der Form nehmen.
Nun muss das Kinderjoy nur noch befüllt werden und
hierfür habe ich mir Nutella in einen Spritzbeutel getan und schneide vorne die Spitze ab.
Und tatsächlich ist im Original Kinderjoy auch im unteren Teil Nutella drin
und deswegen machen wir das jetzt originalgetreu und füllen das Nutella da hinein.
Die helle Creme habe ich mir ebenfalls in einen Spritzbeutel getan und
vorne die Spitze abgeschnitten und gebe das jetzt auf die Nutella.
Mit einem Löffelrücken kann man das jetzt nochmal schön glatt streichen
damit das auch wie im Original aussieht.
Die zwei Crispy Kugeln gebe ich dann noch auf die Oberfläche und
drücke sie ein wenig ein, und dann ist das
XXL Kinderjoy auch schon fertig.
Und hier zeige ich es euch auch nochmal im Vergleich, also
einmal das originale Kinderjoy und meine XXL Variante.
Natürlich hab ich das Kinderjoy nicht alleine gegessen,
ich hatte fleißige Helfer. Es hat aber Riesen Spaß gemacht das zu essen,
vor allem die Kugeln, die haben mir so gut geschmeckt
und falls ihr jetzt auch auf den Geschmack gekommen seid und das Ganze nachmachen möchtet,
dann schaut doch mal in die Infobox, da hab ich alles
aufgeschrieben, was ihr dazu wissen müsst.
Schaut euch auch gerne meine anderen XXL Rezepte an,
ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn ihr mir ein Abo da lasst, damit
ihr auch keines meiner Videos mehr verpasst und
natürlich auch über einen Daumen nach oben.
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!